hey everyone it's Whitney today's show
is gonna be a little different I asked a
friend of mine Donnell Rawlings you know
I'm from Chapelle show the wire
brilliant comedian one of my favorite
people sat down with me and we talked
through what's going on
I hope the conversation speaks for
itself so I'll shut my face and
hopefully you will get as much out of it
as I did Donnell Rawlings
[Music]
you must be in a pretty wild place right
now emotionally I am for so many reasons
pandemic it's got everybody on edge and
then like we were talking about it off
off camera or whatever like this is a
time where comedians are supposed to
stand up you know I'm saying literally
and figuratively speak we can't stand up
literally because you can't do stand-up
comedy you know this is a time where
people want to look for us as an escape
right you know I'm saying that's why
this this are the field that we in it
will test it will stand the test of a
pandemic it will stand the test of
social justice you know right because
people are going to want to be
entertained and this is a town we
supposed to be feeling good and like you
know everybody doesn't feel the way I
feel but I feel weird right now there's
not too many times I say it's probably
in my career maybe three times where
Whitney I didn't feel funny yeah you
know I'm saying whatever your political
views are whatever when Donald Trump was
elected you know I just didn't feel
funny I was numb for an entire week the
whole country was done some people
excited some people weren't I was one of
the people that weren't super excited
about it but I was like Trayvon Martin
when Trayvon Martin when George
Zimmerman got acquitted I was on stage
at pepper bellies when the news broke
right and I was in my that was only
twenty five minutes into my set and it
was like I wasn't funny anymore yeah I
just didn't feel funny I said what can I
do I felt helpless you know the
situation's going on right now I felt
kind of helpless I was like this is when
we're supposed to be funny and I want to
keep all my social media I want you to
go to my page - laughs - laughs - laughs
and I tried to it took a couple days for
me to feel like how am I gonna address
this mm-hmm I was on a roll of being
saying saying funny stuff yeah doing
funny stuff and I'm like yeah people
ain't coming to my page did not felt
like some sense of responsibility mm-hmm
you don't say and I'm like if I can talk
about everything did happen I'm the king
of Tucson Tucson and all and this is the
phrase I use
could be too soon but it never could be
too soon for a funny observation yeah
couldn't find a funny observation with
this I was like eh no jokes what do you
do you starting to build your platform
on your phone you're on your own you're
with your podcast people come here for
funny content and now you want a ship
are you gonna be a a rebel are you gonna
revolt but I knew that I couldn't be
funny
so my page is turned into an expression
of how I feel you know even right now
people tuning is tuned in to your
podcast ha ha ha ha you know but it's a
very tough time because I'm confused you
know I'm saying is some people that live
the lifestyle or their their you know
their whole being is to either be upset
or just all they do is fight for in
justices and stuff like that you got
certain people plays Shaun King page you
know what you're gonna give me goes
chomp King page DL Hughley page you know
you don't get a his page and I'm like
how do you present how do you talk about
this and all that come I was like how do
you feel hmm and I feel this I feel is
fucked up and in this situation
especially in the black community is
that we're almost conditioned for this
to happen it's not shocking anymore yeah
that's the SEPA it's not shocking at one
point it's like what mm-hmm
are you kidding me but now it's more
like here we go again here we go again
and this as we get conditioned to ask
this some fucked-up sides to understand
this is gonna happen the thing that
really fucks the black community up is
like all right we know you motherfuckers
gonna kill us every so often this so
fucked up for me to say this but what
are the consequences what are the
consequences of your action and it's
never a consequence to it you know I'm
saying
um at least we moved to the point where
they started to arrest motherfuckers you
know I'm saying
but it's no it's no there's no
consequence to it and it leaves it peope
puts people in a state of mind
and I said this in my podcast when you
get a black person to put when they say
man it's whatever when someone says it's
whatever that means they're about to do
something and not consider anything that
could cause mende not considering a
career not considering their family did
not consider anything but I gotta do
something about it and that's the fucked
up shit about this you know the fucked
up shit is that okay now any
motherfucker get the rest going to court
but everybody's going home everybody's
being acquitted so we're mad we're
pissed and we're point where what the
fuck can we do
and now people's energy is like eye for
an eye tooth foot it's there was that
quote going around and I I'm gonna ask a
lot of dumb questions
there's no first off first off I respect
that
would you consider dumb statement
because that's how you get to know
people yeah that's how you the way you
get to know somebody is you ask dumb
questions not a dumb question and I
respect the fact you need and said I
respect the fact that you're not even
focus on being funny like you got some
questions I don't represent the whole
black community whatever a bunch I'm not
can represent a whole but I fucked to me
white girls just to I mean black lives
matter but there was one weekend I
wasn't thinking about none of that shit
I was the most unwelcome all the fuck
out there's like you woke I'm sleeping
right there there's like this was just
fire I'm sorry please mom everybody
Rachel Dolezal countess is fucking like
her not
but this is the thing about that it's so
funny we'd like the black cami resort
said did she perpetrate it that she was
black yeah but okay if you really think
about it what does she care about what
was she a champion for mm-hmm what was
she arguing about black shit so and
right now I'm gonna tell you we need
some white people we need some white
people to eggs dunk questions and get
answers again I represent all black
American tell you my experience how I
feel about it you mean go from there
and I think that there's you know and
for me my deal is and I know this is you
know I'm getting a lot of people that
you know asked some questions and a lot
of their questions were well what if I
say the wrong thing or what if I am I
allowed to post a MLK quote am I being
performative you know and I think that
right now it's see being not racist
isn't enough anymore it's white people
need to very aggressively be anti-racist
so the thing is Whitney okay what if I
sit around the ground think what is the
wrong thing what are your thoughts right
right
what what what could you say wrong and I
got one of my friends a close friend of
mine he's in economy business and I'll
say it I'll leave names out but I pretty
much say he's built to career off a
black culture mm-hmm I'll just say that
out flat you know the most success that
you've had is through black culture the
reason why people come to you as a white
person in this business is a lot of
times when black people don't want to
necessarily think do they need to work
with white writers and stuff like that
they come to you in like this artistic
cool white white guy that knows our
culture that knows how we speak you know
I'm saying that has had some experiences
that's been around us you know you built
off of that and it's kind of disturbing
to me because just like you say am I
gonna say the wrong thing just no such
thing as the wrong thing and at the end
of the day what's in your heart how do
you feel and don't make this about your
discomfort not any that's not your
problem that's no one's problem there's
an ego and you getting it wrong no one
gives a shit right so but I did you know
find over what's going on right now just
amplifying other voices
the step in the right direction yeah NAT
light last couple of days you start
seeing and some people like oh I think
just it just just it's faked whatever
you see some cops did a march on some
people in Miami to Miami the police
department when protests were coming
their way to start there wherever they
were supposed to line up to protest they
all got on their knees
you know I'm Sam and and people want to
judge I would like oh I think it's phony
whatever but the fact that but as a
black person we feel and we don't need
it we feel like you think this is as
fucked up as I think and it comes down
to we can say colored on it but it's
like this situation especially this
situation this situation was a situation
where it wasn't you always use all they
were they were they were resisting
arrest they were violent or whatever
we've seen all the video every angle
that this guy wasn't resisting arrest
and also I think that you know something
that I'm words are important and in my
opinion we're throwing around the word
police brutality that was not police
brute that wasn't murder I mean we were
we watched a murder happen right right
so it's also I think about changing the
vocabulary used to even have this
conversation I mean people have went to
the extremity first happened in lynching
and it felt like yeah and the thing
about is like like who's gonna stand
around and just watch it Lynch you don't
have any concern about it you don't
think it's fucked up you don't want to
say I think it's wrong you know I'm
saying that situation was unfortunate
that situation unfortunate and it was it
was just it was just it was just gross
it was disgusting anybody to watch
anybody watch that video yeah that would
even try to think what did he do your
fucked up person yeah you're a
psychopath I mean and also just the and
it's so unfortunate this is what it had
to come to for white people to
understand I mean the nonchalance the
casual nature of this I mean I just I
don't I don't think once you've seen
that video you can ever go back you can
never unsee you smirk let me tell you
something black new don't like Smurfs we
are upset when Ari Shaffir how you say
his last name
Saphir I want to bring bring up all news
whatever but you know I thought it was
when his shit was out that there was
more of a bad joke to anything right I
said but a thing that was very very very
insisting it was the smart like even
with that that do his his his pocket
yes hands pocket like I don't give a
fuck what nobody say or what they do
this is going down like this and then
his buddy
is sitting there pretty like he's like
every mine did it reminded me and I've
never been this appears but I've heard
is like I like and like a motherfucker
violating a woman right you frat party
type shit you know something is fucking
going on in that other room but you're
on the outside so you don't think you're
involved but you still a participant cuz
you did you didn't step it you didn't
say that's right that's right you didn't
say anything and you think that's good
that's why it's important right now
there's a lot of issues that we have to
deal with but it's important right now
the other three cops have to be they
they have to be a risk that's right
because it's not it's I think what
people way too late are starting to
understand is that it's just it's not
one cop that's not that was the the
system that enabled that to happen when
the the it was so complicit and the the
in human nature I mean there's I'm just
trying to describe the feeling of that
it was just sickening it was like it was
sickening
it was sickening in a way that I I don't
think we can ever turn back from this
does this feel like a bigger moment does
this feel I feel like it's so that we
got so many cases of this happening
right right I feel a bit like the
difference that I feel with this
situation is that a lot of people are
upset it's just not one community just
upset
Amish people were protesting yeah came
out with their fuckin buggies yeah
because it was like the excuses you
normally use a belligerent violent
resisting arrest all that type of shit
all the bull show ambiguity none of it
you know I'm saying and that's what
makes it so bad and
like you know going back to his saying
about you know some of your friends they
respond to it whatever one of my friends
I was talking to him about it and he was
like and I know that in his heart he has
some concern yeah but he was like I
wanted to help but I don't know what to
do yes and like your personal posts
every day something right you could
start with that that's right you can
start with you can start with I I feel
bad this is so fucked up
but I don't know what to do open your
fucking I know can with like social
media is the best way to get to people
open your comments up they'll tell you
some people like fuck you white boy we
don't need you or whatever but then you
might have somebody like I appreciate
the fact that you understand that and
then your understanding if somebody is
filled with rage and they like fuck all
white people it might be your concern or
the fact that you you had a heart that
might stop them from doing something to
you it's a whole mindset and like I
believe that you know hopefully
hopefully things will change but I know
in this case in this situation it's got
to be more than just black people being
upset about it that's right there's got
to be more than that and when does and I
think that it you know this is all been
so fucked up it took a second to like
figure out what should go on social
media because frankly I think a lot of
people post for Klout and prefer you
know to get likes and all this rate and
it feels disingenuous and it feels phony
and it feels in our community in our
community along with me our community
and longing I know people and I'm
talking about people that are low to
some other fuckers now I can understand
I you know I can understand some people
like well I'm just getting started you
know I mean I don't want to burn any
bridges you know I'm saying I know this
is gonna upset these people I need to
get my money on but I'm talking about
motherfuckers I know that's rich they
probably never have to work again they
don't have to deal with how it's gonna
affect them financially just do you care
yeah and they fucking don't they don't
want to come up they don't want to step
up and I feel bad I want one of my
Instagram last I was like white people
we need you yes I pleaded I said white
people I'll say here's
I'm gonna do not gonna have sex with any
more white girls until we fix this
listen rolling together that's it I
don't know if you can like take your
dick back you know what squirt
that's that squirt that multiple orgasm
is shit you know what you didn't fucking
deserve that and you know how hard it
would be to say you know how harsh me to
say that you know how hard it is for me
to say that Whitney is fucking tough do
you know how hard is for me to look a
white woman in her face and say you know
what no more fucking Brussels sprouts
huh
gir this will be say Whitney look now I
come to your house you got fucking nuts
with no salt everywhere Whitney I judge
you yo yo these are white people nuts
there's no fucking glaze on it there's
no roasted almonds there's no salt
vinegar
there's no wasabi these are straight
nuts you know Heidi's you know how it is
you know what you know what I did
Whitney you know what I did with me I
changed my diet for your people and this
one I get UNAMI times I've stroll
through the farmer's market by myself as
a fuckin black man you met the white
girl all of them do you know how hard it
was to fucking go to the hood I'll be
with my black friends then say I wanna
arugula salad okay
you think that's a hard thing to do
Whitney I want a fuckin arugula salad
and I don't want any dressing oil art is
for me to recycle Whitney you don't know
that do you you don't know that you know
why cuz I grew up with me with trash was
fuckin yo deed harder yes I grew up
where Chuck
we caught it with me we caught a trash
fucking can
and guess what goes in the trash care
with me trash trash yep okay I don't
give a fuck of his aluminum foil I don't
give a stick
I don't give a fuck what it was fucking
trash now you have two trash cans none I
gotta get and I do that for your people
your people
thanks you guys just the fuckin yeah
exactly you can't do a post you're not
much pressure I'm putting on my white
friends I'm like this don't donate your
money post is fuckin picture just give
me a post motherfucker has it been
disappointing how few people have posted
about this it's been disciplined
disappointing yes yes it has with this
one and then it's been disappointing for
I feel like I'm like a recruiter like
the white people that call I'm not
calling white people I'm at I'm not
trying to reach all YP yeah but the ones
that I know the ones I love in it's like
did we talk about everything else
what do you care about how does this
make you feel what's the block what's
I've never liked a block is
motherfuckers this is the block
motherfuckers I'm not gonna have racist
fans no don't lie is that a lot if the
block is um I I don't want to lose my
fucking fans what do you want races vans
like what
I wanna walk okay I'm sorry I want them
all for the fucker you could show up to
my show which of Magha hat or my fucker
I'll have a locker room I want all the
fucking money and I don't myself but I
do today like this is the truth of that
Winnie and the truth of it is like you
know I travel with Chappelle a lot right
and people who come out just repel show
there are a lot of Trump there everybody
so I believe this comedy is the one
thing that's an example of how come you
can bring everybody together
yes you know I'm saying like um on my
podcast
uh I had a phone line set up for people
to call it right and I threw the number
idea and never really checked it the
other day
if someone's playing on the phones and I
got this voice mess and it was a fucking
dopest message cuz I was it was his wife
I know he's white dude and I am profound
him his tones like is this donnell
rawlings if this is dawnia Rawlings he
said I want to say man I like your
podcast I like you on on the Joe Rogan
show I like you on the Chappelle show
and I was listening one in your podcast
and you said you said you were talking
about living your blank you say you're
talking about living your blank and you
say it you got the beginning of your
life you got the blank in the middle
until you got the in and the most
important thing is what do you do with
your blank that's what he said but I
didn't say blank I said - but in fact it
he fall along his story he said it what
do you do with your blank and then he
said he said and no I said cracker cuz
this was the shit was I put a cracker
back I didn't want to use crack nut no
more and this was Jesus I'm gonna miss
that but it's not as effective it
doesn't hit his head does it doesn't the
reason why you know how you you ingrain
words when it's following a whip nigga
wouldn't have been nigga wouldn't have
been his strong without a will if you
had a tickler nigger he is different but
when you is a whole different right you
know so it didn't do and then he was
like he said and he was talking about
your debt you're in your blank he said
you know what I'm gonna live my blank he
said I'm going to underwater welding
school don't laugh with me no but yo it
made me face it some words that I said
yeah he said I'm going to underwater
welding school and I'm gonna make
something of my life he said you know
what cuz I always talk about how dope it
is to be a day said I'm gonna be
good dad inhale I might be gone through
six months at a time and they're gonna
miss me when I come back whoo-wee
whenever I do sis whoo-wee
he said it's gonna be poppin man and
then he said whoo tang
he said Wooten wu-tang is the period you
know Moo tank pumps weights everything
hmm he said Wooten and and it meant so
much to me because I'm saying to myself
this is who I affect that's why I say I
don't care who kind of my show I want
everybody come to my show this will
affect a motherfucking black dude from
DC to grew up poor and all that type of
shit affected this dude yeah so that's
why that's why I don't want to just I'm
not of the notion like fuck all white
people I don't want to say that I don't
even want to look at you side I I don't
want to think like oh you wanted him you
you you wanted him I wanted to say the
way I'd see you when I see you I want to
feel that same way and I want to sell it
was feel that way about my friends but I
will say that in a situation you
starting to find people's character yeah
they're real character in those people
everybody smiley face you you know they
like the relationship like we're cool as
shit but some people only cool with you
because it's an opportunity get
something with you in a not real fucking
friends they benefit and if you gonna be
if you gonna be my friend right then at
least understand me at least understand
me
they should hate that this one my close
friends yeah you know like um when Kanye
West was going through the whole
marriage thing and my focus wanted to
know how they felt about it you know of
course it did and him he considered
Kanye his brother so you can't pick all
your family members whatever then but
the play smells like you have I got a
relationship with you you got a
different relationship you would you
know I can't just judge him on there
because I understand him a different way
and like a couple of handful of people
that caught I called my folks and I
thought there's gonna be ready to ride
police have understanding or at least
understand what's frustrating to black
people
you motherfuckers quickness
motherfuckers quick to say but what
about all the deficit Chicago
motherfucking anybody talking about that
shit I know that's a problem and I know
that in the black community we got to
check out self too
we got to do things so people can't
throw that in your face yeah but you
know how many cops kill black people how
many you kill you kill your own people
okay but this feels different and it
feels fucked up did you feel how did you
feel about killer Mike speech getting so
much I thought it was a great speech I
thought was a great speech and I thought
it was like it was honest and this is
the point what I'm saying like in even
midday he wish you were had so other
things to say but that's because you're
trying to that's if you prepare it so
you said earlier okay say what the fuck
is in your heart yeah that's gonna be
your truth and I'm glad that he made a
point to say you can't burn your own
shit up and that's the truth mm-hmm but
didn't on the other side you can't you
can't say an entire movement is that
represent I'm right right if you quick
to say with the police and wife was
quick to say there's always a couple of
bad apples in a bunch if you go to the
fucking grocery store and you see a bag
of apples it one is rotten you ain't
fucking with that bag yo if you see one
fucked up great Whitney you ain't gonna
be like oh I'm just gonna pick that
great it's like the whole bag right here
if I see one burnt nut I'm like try two
boys me with the goddamn bird nuts I
know it's a teaser of what's to cause
what's good with the other nut you like
just these nothing right right yeah I
know my nuts all right so that's say if
that is your understanding that in this
situation the cop it's like it's always
a bad apple then don't try to say the
motherfuckers that are fucking rioting
or all the people on the side of getting
some justice and getting some answers
that's not the case because those
motherfuckers
that's uh stealing shit and burning shit
them motherfuckers are criminals that
need it an opportunity to steal and do
fucked up shit and here's another thing
if you want to go deeper into that so
how can we eliminate a situation where
people are crazy where you have to
decide okay are you gonna be this is
gonna be good or evil you know I'm
saying if if this situation wouldn't
happen we wouldn't have no motherfucking
protest so you wouldn't have to sift out
who the fucked up people are or whatever
gonna be quite honest I watched these
riots Whitney mhm
you know what was in your stealing shit
the Mexicans please stay on him for this
please don't go to my single yo Whitney
I'm telling you Whitney I love the
cholos of the Coyotes all above but them
the only motherfuckers as was Luton man
who da fuck steals fine dresses from
Target if they're not fucking Mexican on
Salvadorian my son is a quarter Salvador
he loves pop poses and I'm sorry for
saying that shit but it's the odds
goddamn truth man Whitney fuck still
fucking flip flop daughter pandemic
Whitney the motherfucking Mexicans we
now take a pause in our program to have
a word from our sponsors Benton you
there oh yeah
Oh fancy my what even this Lina take a
break I'm an elegant host of a radio
program do you have a problem
okay Benton first of all you're jealous
of me and it's obvious second of all I
don't want to talk about article the way
you do cuz I don't know if you know
anything about me but I don't need to
read ads off the copy like these play
like the phoniest podcast hosts out
there I actually use the products that
sponsor the podcast because I'm not a
huckster who's completely full of Phooey
I have article furniture in my home meet
you
tell me about yours I personally love
mine I have a couch I have a rug I'm a
big big fan tell me about the rug cuz
the rugs are poppin gah
oh yeah the rugs are perfect for your
low for your little piglets to walk
through what little piglets you know you
guys will pay lift on your feet you got
a walk through your net cushy rug you're
met this metaphor is going to a weird
place how would you describe the look of
article furniture don't be too sexual
try to control yourself you know me I
would say article is very like modern
millennial classic mid-century
Scandinavian bohemian a dash of bohemian
would you say Viking that means durable
is my guess I have the outside my
favorite new chairs are what would you
call it it's like um it's like what
would you call it I'd like industrial
kind of yes it's industrial but very
fresh Frosch would like I'm in on a boat
in Finland that's how I feel that I sit
on my chairs I feel like I'm way
classier than I am you did put them
together quickly I sure did I was
excited and then when I bought those in
the rug I was shocked by how affordable
they were fair prices you save up to 30%
over traditional retail prices why why
else because you can keep their prices
low by cutting out the middleman and
selling directly there's no showrooms no
salespeople no retail markups fast
affordable shipping available across the
US and Canada and free on orders over
how much and how long does it take for
in stock items to be delivered can we
say yes article is offering our
listeners $50 off your first purchase of
$100 or more go to article comm slash
Whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout okay
article dot-com / Whitney to get $50 off
your first purchase
of $100 or more per usual
the sponsor the next thing I'm gonna
read is a company I've used for years a
pill I've taken for years what's a call
Benton
it's called ritual you guys want to know
why my hair is so lustrous and well my
skin is so goddamn luminescent it's
because I take ritual vitamins I love it
it's what you want to help do you want
to go go I'm so healthy I've just taught
my brain is moving so fast cuz I take
these vitamins that I keep cutting you
off
go ahead Benton you want a healthy body
you want a Maserati vitamins from you it
has d3 2 Omega 3 rituals essential for
women helps fill gaps and a woman's diet
which I need because I eat mostly trash
and sugar there are no nausea capsule
design is gentle on an empty stomach and
there's a mint tab in every bottle to
keep things fresh which my lover really
appreciates so my breath my breath
doesn't smell like Worf all the time
that's the problem with fish oil pills
is that you burp them up for the rest of
the day you're like is that a scallop
you want your lover to think he's dating
a cat actually might like that ritual is
traceable and payment for obsessive
label readers all of rituals
vegan-friendly
sugar free non-gmo gluten-free allergen
free sometimes you look in the
ingredients your vitamins and there's
all sorts of weird shit in there like
red number 5 and benzodiazepine and dyes
bad news
sometimes vitamins are scams not ritual
and the best thing could I tell you this
is gonna sound like I'm reading it but
I'm not looking at the youtubes and see
that I'm not reading my computer the
problem with vitamins is that you forget
to order more so you always end up
lapsing Giunta mean and then it messes
up your whole flow and then your hair
starts to get brittle and you start to
get less energy and then you have such
little energy
you can't reorder the goddamn pills and
your memory goes bad so you forget
ritual subscribe you subscribe you have
two left it's at your door waiting
through a third
delivered you have no say in the matter
you're gonna be healthy whether you like
it or not better health does not happen
overnight
and right now ritual is offering my
listeners 10% off during your first
three months fill in the gaps in your
diet with essential for women a small
step that helps support a healthy
foundation for your body visit ritual
calm / Whitney to start your ritual
today that's ten percent off during your
first three months at ritual calm /
Whitney guys great gift for your lady to
give her beautiful skin no split ends
and a soft skin on her tush ain't no
black people in there lutein no fucking
target locker is different lady for
lager yo lady foot William fuck Jordans
Jordans no give up fuck who is fucking
stealing from Target son
Whitney they try to pay back people dead
they was looting Starbucks
niggas ain't stealing no Starbucks I
showed a dela video earlier of white
girls that were rioting blacklivesmatter
on this revolution yo yo three and a
half years great no it was four it was
four solid years so you're used to
playing nuts huh no I'm not used to no
fucking nut you got cluster of nuts over
there yeah these have shit this is okay
look at that that's got all stop trying
to save my life I'm ready to ride for
these motherfuckers rather die in here
tries the pre-existing aggression okay
whatever Whitney if you ask me how many
miles you got your
I'm leaving this fucking or just I mean
I'm leaving this goddamn podcast right
now if you ask me how many steps that
clown doing the motherfucking pandemic
and riots you don't care about my people
know where to start planking after this
Rogen's gonna come on I used to play I
was a plank of motherfuck I did all that
that's called that's how you get whites
his plank eat yogurt yogurt eat yogurt
to talk about traveling and you can get
some stamps on your passport they ready
for you didn't be interesting what do
you got India yoga be worldly fucking
donate to a nonprofit organization not
white chicks that work for nonprofit
organizations Oh what trust fund kids
trust funky yes I know you I know you we
grew up in the same area what school did
you go to DC where I went to I got
kicked out of a couple but I ended up
graduating from a place outside DC and
Potomac called st. Andrews San Angeles
yeah my sister went to Whitman in
Churchill Churchill that's in Virginia
yeah yeah right outside you don't know
how many points you get as a black man
if you could take a Churchill chick down
yo let me tell you something it was
certain levels to this shit yo ma was
like I see you if you could take take a
Churchill chick down if she was on the
swim team
she was on a crew team in the ten more
extra points and if you could take one
down to kept a secret from mom and dad
that's another 20 points no but if you
could give you could get a white chick
that was right here between losing their
trust fund that was another one losing
their trust fund in their place with God
I do
I did I did I did it despite your
Italian chick right and we broke her
they say was trust issues as well her
mother her dad say if you don't leave
this motherfucker long you're gonna lose
your trust fund guess what I was out the
door and I loved her that's devastating
it was what that wasn't her she now can
look her up on Facebook I can't say he's
not giving it up but you where's she now
she picked her as she's she's a doctor
mmm have a trust fund you become a dark
it's a waste of assessment I had I
didn't have a chance but it's kind of
tough right now how do you talk to your
son about all this or have you does he
know this or not
I try to keep it away from I'm just the
way can I just say we facetimed earlier
and you said what kind of potato chips
do you want what flavor and he said oh
yeah nobody thing about it is like the
weird thing about is dead
it just no I won't say just not just got
comfortable on their arm Coronas shit
but he's not disturbed by that and then
we doing a corona shit now this this you
let him watch the news do you let him
see what's going to sit yeah he knows
what's going on I haven't I've you know
it's great good question I haven't
really explained to what's going on with
the fires yeah you know sir but the
corona joint and it was like that's kind
of tough but he said something to me the
other day and it really made me feel
good because he said he said I'm daddy
he called it the Rona yeah he's like
daddy
he said daddy we going outside so he
said oh let me bring my hand sanitizer
yes he said I would take my hand
sanitizer
and then he said daddy you know the best
thing about the Romo I said what he said
I get to spend more time and more daddy
Sun time right yeah every when I was
driving up here today I was like how max
I'm not gonna explain this to you how am
I gonna explain to him that a
motherfucker Kawana caused bodily harm
to you just because of your skin color a
motherfucker
can be threatened by your skin color and
in case we just wanna fuck what's the
fucking Lord the DA police named um
Derek whatever the fuck his name yeah
kratae is crack but is it this is how
white America is so threatened by a
black man that when you have someone
apprehended you have him restrained you
have him on the ground and as for
motherfuckers on him you still feel he's
a threat and I haven't figured out a way
to explain that to my son
I don't I can't teach my son all white
people are fucked up I don't want to
teach you that and I don't want him to
believe that and I can't have him
believe it because the school he go to
is only two black motherfuckers in it
anyway so I can't teach and I gotta find
a way to explain these things to him
just so you can be aware of them and
just so he could try to be safe want to
say yet police you motherfuckers
you work for me I'm a taxpayer I pay my
taxes shit you don't talk to me like dad
talk to you but I got explained to him
him feel that way could cost him his
fucking life do you think about that
when you raise him I watching the killer
Mike speech it just became so clear if
you haven't thought about this before
not only do you have to carry the anger
the ancestral trauma of all this the
anger but you also have to behave a
certain way and restrain yourself you
had a restraint but everybody's not
gonna be that way some people do
motherfuckers I told you about it's
whatever
some people are gone yeah some people
are gone nice try mm-hmm some people
gone and you always do the comparison
you got the motherfuckers with the dr.
Martin Luther King way of thinking then
you got the Malcolm X way think I'm
crossed between both of them I'm crossed
between both of them that part of me
wants to say peace peaceful protesters
sit down and talk about it but you can't
keep hitting me in my fucking head
that's right you know I'm saying already
know if I was being I was here dr. King
out this first time I got hit I didn't
like yell I'm going to create Malcolm X
when you March mmm cuz I want to fight
that but we didn't see how it did
advance civil rights to not
act out of rage you don't saying it may
sound crazy to some other fuckers but on
dr. King's thoughts but it does make
sense down you ain't giving them a
reason to say no you ain't give them a
reason to fuck with you you like okay I
want to meet you right here but some
other fuckers don't learn by that it's
not gonna make a difference and you got
what we call in the streets and go hard
niggas we got some motherfuckers out
there like I said that don't have
anything to live for you compound a
motherfucker that don't have anything to
live for doing a pandemic motherfucker
ain't working
he just waiting to set it off and it
could be something simple some
motherfuckers on edge like that back to
what I said it's whatever you can be
people have that so stupid you could
catch the motherfucker you step on his
shoes around time if you've already got
to spin up immunity they have no outlet
you given him an outlet mm-hmm uuuuuugh
killing us you give this motherfucker
outlet I couldn't wait to get at these
motherfucking white dudes
thank you very much and imma set it off
and we in and I'll be quite honest
any movement needs some go hard
motherfuckers that's it
you got the motherfuckers that are like
we keep talking shit keep that it was an
if that was a nine woods nine and a half
minutes that video there was a nine and
a half minutes of just what am i what a
good friend of mine
there's there III don't know how this
can be a calm conversation character
what we see I a good friend of mine
who's very smart guy went to he was one
Barack Obama's classmate right and
whenever things like this happen when
Donald Trump got like I call him cuz I
I'm in tune with the streets but I want
to see what the I believe motherfuckers
and what they think about it and even
when I went Trump got it it was like he
was so common he was like Donna um it's
gonna be okay
it's gonna be good he said
we got understand that um Hillary she
was a flawed kid she was she was flawed
so we are we stepped into it yeah you
know and even with the situation with
this and as much as he thinks that there
is a need for protests hmm
he thinks there's a need for anger but
what he said and this what people got
understand this we got it
we gotta just take a minute to just calm
down for a second yeah see what we want
out of this okay this is something
that's troubling to our community for
years but right now what we need is
those other three officers to be
arrested if a black man shot a white
dude and he was with three other
motherfuckers hmm they not just gonna
say get the gunman they're gonna be like
did you talk about it did you think
about it were you there what happened to
conspiracy why are these motherfuckers
that you were a part of it and you're
gonna be just as responsible and and
what you know and four people and I want
to ask some dumb questions and some that
were no such things don't send into dumb
question when is one these nuts really
don't have no salt maybe one of them is
salty like you have sought free nuts
these are Corona free you heard of
because it existing conditions well if
he's got a better shot you got a better
shot to survive
that video you know I think it was maybe
Will Smith I might be misquoting saying
you know it's not that racism has gotten
worse it's just been filmed right yeah
but here you saw that that quote going
around that video it wasn't just
like this it was clear that this man's
life was not as valuable as a white
person's life I mean it was yo the
casual wit nature the motherfucker yeah
yeah just one thing yeah yeah this is
one thing yeah that's already fuck yeah
yeah yeah yeah awful and I don't yet not
even giving a fuck if nobody is looking
at you not even a care in the world
as if let's kill this nigga get him to
the truck and get the fuck out of here I
got lunch in an hour that's how I
fucking felt watching this and holla
with me this is so fucked up this is
what so fucked up that video was a
painful video to watch just with one
angle that's right with when you first
saw that shit Whitney you like this wait
a minute how is it you could just tell
that it was a big dude you know how is
it just like he's just so calm like this
and then we was like that was enough to
fuckin get people furious and then when
you reversed it and you saw three other
motherfuckers come on so when people say
sad thing about it Whitney I'm sorry to
tell the same thing about it white women
have spoken long enough those please
interrupt me you know and it's only fair
and a fun thing about it with seeing
that with this is the fucked-up thing
about it Whitney which seeing it like
it's like it was one time where you like
ohoo taja Oh
hearsay no witnesses with that said you
got three different angles
you got a fucking angle of when they
first confronted him then you know I'm
saying you got an angle by a car my
question I was having himself how did he
get on the ground
not yet you know I'm Sam yeah how did he
get on the ground like I was like how
did it look so calm how do you get on
the ground you know I mean you probably
jerked him something like oh you're
funny but yo he's down here don't nobody
know nobody this
helping him the Asian dude is like the
lookout dude yeah and here's a fucking
thing about it
with four tapes for videos this band is
doing is dead
black people feel like you know what
there is a good chance did this
motherfucker might get acquitted there's
a good chance and that's how we don't
feel comfortable with the system right
you say like this that's a no-brainer
that's like oh please Joe that's murder
we have three angles of her murderers
gone
you already see what it's RAM dunk a
dance now what are you trying to say
Oh pre-existing conditions
oh we probably died of heart attack he
died of a heart attack cuz he wouldn't
if he went into shock you did yeah you'd
have a heart attack too you know I'm
saying well the first thing you can see
you're in shit yeah coming from up under
the fucking truck and to think and what
I think is worth consider this was
pisses me off Whitney hmm my bitch-ass
fucking friends don't even want to talk
about it my bitch-ass friends they love
to post hardy-har-har hee hee shit they
don't even want to talk about it they
don't think it means anything
so that's how you feel didn't how does a
country really fucking feel there is
unsalted if you're gonna take my
sunflower seeds at least enjoy them oh
my god oh my god no I don't I don't
actually tastes a lot like sunflowers
oh no about that I did not know that
dick I even had a taste that's all
straight I am tastes like like ass no no
but black guy
she's black she's Daniels candy that's
right ladies and gents and we want to
change the world
we gonna do a one candle at a fuck yeah
this is thick this is the the good for
you house candle you like to smell it I
love it that was an example of me
dealing with disruptive strategy mm-hmm
yeah I'm Sam and when the padam aquinnah
pendant that pandemic shit kicked off I
was like you're unemployed comedian what
are you gonna do hmm
you continue to do your podcast and
you're gonna come up with some type of
merchandise did you think that um people
interested in buying it when I first
came out I know this is off subject but
you know me candle that'll fix it so
right boom we can hold for a second I
got a cell mechanic it's got black ass
man black ass matters I know black Raj
Babbar black ass let's just hold civil
rights for one second all right we'll be
right back to your time Mike and black
ass is a Cadillac came an idea came up
with and it's a very why don't you how
much it's been used I know I like that
every like you'll make fun of all the
shit that I have out on my table and the
podcast table I got drinks and hairspray
and makeup and shit but I always have
this candle here to please and I'll
explain it as you go and we'll get back
wait a minute we'll get back to civil
rights in one second
from Marcy projects to Hollywood Darnell
captured six true smells of going from
ashy to classy bring them the memories
of cold air hitting your skin on a
winter's day shades of your skin getting
ash here and as sure as the brief as the
brisk wind hit your arms and ankles
capture the energy of a good lotion
without having it black ash eliminates
the smells of twerk and replaces it with
exotic smells bergamont
sandalwood musk lavender jasmine and
ambergris how many of those ingredients
do you know I eat all of them on a daily
basis I should have known a white woman
no no I shouldn't know that shit
ambergris have you eat ambergris that's
what I use as Lube you know about
and amber I mean I know amber ambergris
wait a minute it's like bergamot I know
this amethyst what does ambergris from I
don't know
ambergris is the product by product of a
whales whales vomit you heard it here
first
yes when I first went about when my um
when my um fragrant Shore uh-huh was
explaining to me I was like what is
ambergris she wasn't totally familiar
with it and she said it's whale sperm I
actually looking for a donor currently a
what for a child you want to really stop
a civil-rights you really want yo you
really wanna I don't give a fuck and his
name is Tyrol no members yes it's a waxy
flammable substance of dull gray or
blackish color produced in the digestive
system of sperm whales yes and it's like
freshly produced ambergris has a marine
fecal odor yes it's a very distinct odor
and it's like in the whole game of
fragrances it's like it's a big deal if
you can want to compare it to like the
culinary world
it's the truffles of all flips of sperm
wheels Wow
your truffles of sperm water so people
even actually it's a truffle it's it's
just like it's the truffles of sperm
whales or whales of sperm oh no vomit
yes that is a certain type of who
discovered this what this is some
serious kink I'm pretty sure was a white
person I mean I could white woman found
this it was a white guy there's a white
guy we don't really have we don't have
as much an America we don't have as much
issues with white women as two white
guys stay away from her I'm gonna say it
then they're listening hey guys you know
about this thing called June gloom
Benton I dunno did you have that back in
the outskirts of Nashville I was pretty
much always depressed so probably this
isn't describing an emotional
State this is describing and out in
California we call June gloom they just
say that because it rhymes which is
ridiculous it's just something that
caught on you know because it was a good
hashtag but I don't think June June has
to be gloomy Junie doesn't have to be
gloomy the Sun is out birds are chirping
we're getting out of the woods on this
pandemic you're gonna you know you're
it's time to here's what I'm getting to
I'm trying to revenge I'm that's better
I'm just you know what let's just cut to
the chase your nether regions are
important and my guess is that you're
putting trash garbage all over it
you're using polyester using some nasty
spandex I've seen some of y'all's
underwear it's disgusting
and you need to class it up you bunch of
pigs okay it's time to get me undies
you've heard about it you've heard about
a lot of the podcasts you've heard about
me and East I know you have and guess
what I had heard about it too and I
thought I don't know how good can
underwear be and then Benton over here
ordered me a pair unbelievable was like
a terrific it was like scribed in four
years silky they're smooth they're
magical they're the best underwear you
could possibly wear and you can
subscribe a subscription or deliver em
right to your door every month you may
never have you underwear again you just
wait a month get a new pair it's like a
hug for your undercarriage yeah it's
your old ones in the freezer no we don't
put things in the freezer we put and
underwear it'll they lose their
elasticity these are like tight and stay
put without feeling like a violent
wedgie do you think yeah their skin
they're like a second skin that's it and
you order me a pair with little llamas
on it my lover really likes those okay
no but the thongs you most thongs feel
like you're getting sawed in half let's
be honest these are like they kind of
just caress your butthole and they just
hold it like they just kind of give a
nice support to your sphincter yeah they
just whispers
nothing that's it it's like a gentle
caress instead of like a strangulation
which most thongs do this thong I almost
peed through it the other day I didn't
realize it was on that's how lightweight
they are I had to be like uh-oh
oops I'm actually wearing underwear and
they're caught in what the best court is
me undies has a great offer for you're
listening for any first-time purchasers
you can get 50% off and free shipping
this is a no-brainer especially because
they have a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee to get your 15% off your first
pair and free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed slash Whitney
that's Mandy / Whitney tada
today or tada get out exactly uh so
we're in a pandemic people are staying
home because they don't want to get an
invisible virus feels like a perfect
time to do what Benton perfect time to
potentially learn a language truly right
should be able to to talk to all those
international lovers that you've taken
that you've met on your dating sites you
know once you've torn through every
American it's now time to go
international learn a language so you
can flirt with some Italians because
they're gonna be excited for a while -
they'll be really impressive when I can
say more than just a lady Marmol on
Dirks
[Music]
babble is designed to quickly get you
speaking your new language within weeks
Wow
with daily 10 to 15 minutes sessions oh
that's great you do it every day that's
the problem with me I need to repeat
something every day in order to really
drill it into my thick skull but badly
this is good babble teaches real life
conversations you're not learning words
and phrases out of context that's how I
learned French it was just like a burly
boob froze it like I learned just weird
random I know a lot of phrases but I
can't actually have a conversation yeah
I can look after the Nazis k'ittain oh
my god which means shut up talking to me
bable works because it's built around
real-life how people actually
communicate and what they actually care
about lessons are thoughtfully created
by over a hundred language experts real
human beings not computers and robots
and not by a translation machine and
their teaching method has been proven to
be effective across multiple studies
with Babel you can choose from 14
different languages which one do you
want to do Benton I can speak to some of
my mom's family oh that's a very good
one I want to become an alcoholic so
that I can start talk to my mom's family
spanish french german the speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accent that's
genius and babel is available as an app
or online so your progress will be
synced all across devices let me tell
you like i feel like everyone has 15
minutes a day and the amount of time
that i just scroll instagram like
looking at x's feeds i could have
learned a language english there's no
excuse not to do this it's not daunting
it's not too time-consuming three months
free with the purchase of a three month
subscription I'm gonna try it called
Whitney I was gonna try to do that in
French to show you guys how much I need
to learn French right now what is it
Babel yes I know stop is three months
subscription that's da BPEL com promo
code with Babel language from life but
what if it learned from dating white
women besides that
nuts don't have salt enough salt I don't
know um the white woman I have dated
we're all cool in fact who I did the
white shoe that was speaking of earlier
she I went to where she grew up to visit
you know it's a one of those
neighborhoods where like just don't see
a lot of interracial couples and I was
holding her hand and I was told I said
you know we really got to go that hard
you know I'm saying I'm not you know you
trying to show me that you really care -
oh we don't really have to go that hard
you know I don't want you to feel
uncomfortable she was like Thalia don't
be stupid she said if we're not
comfortable everybody else gonna be
uncomfortable and she at heart you know
I'm saying I knows people it's easy for
people say who you shouldn't date with
or anything like that but watch as I had
dated they'd been cool black cheese I
had dated been cool and I never but it
was for me before I stayed at dating her
and when I used to kick her white chicks
or whatever smashing whatever I always
do it this was my thing always thought
like yeah I'm having fun I'm connecting
whatever but I always thought did on
this it was something that would block
us from taking it to the next level
because I think two of the toughest
loves you can have is a interracial love
and um and um you know black and gay and
gay love because it's not well known as
it's a different thing but it was one of
the things like it's not supposed to be
like that this isn't the way it is it'll
not be accepted my family won't
appreciate and all that type of stuff
it's not illegal it's not legal yeah a
whole bunch of shit was always something
we're always I always felt like it was
something that'll be like this okay
that's the reason and I'm out you know
but when I dated her none of that
mattered and another reason was so dope
when I did there because at the time I
was starting to get some success in the
business right yeah and uh she had a job
where she was overseas right
and I was popping off the Chappelle's
Show
she didn't know that she was on another
continent she didn't know that she the
place really had a lot of TVs or
anything and I remember we were going
out we're out one day and I went to the
bathroom and these guys kept on hovering
around I went to the bathroom I came
back and um one of the guys said to her
do you know what that is
issues like no who is it right she and
that was a kind of connect cuz it wasn't
like she was kicking away because I was
Ashley Larry being like she had a
connection she had a connection me so I
knew when I was when we were dating it
it was genuine I mean another reason I
knew it because she was from a wealthy
family - Emma one time she started when
she started to get to know like all this
was a guy from Chappelle's Show
I went I was walking down the street and
somebody said I'm really she said me too
killed it was like the career path she
chose was it just didn't make sense you
know I said I was comedian profession
she was it was like they just totally
opposite we weren't like it was we had a
great time and their relationship some
great Fred the best the only time I had
to break up with when I broke up I was
like thank you mmm you know it's like
yes it was real like hey Daniel I'm
doing this you're doing that you're on
this course on this coast just goes you
know I love you but it just doesn't make
sense chin it was just it was mature it
wasn't trying to find somebody a glass
there we go I'm out of here
you know I mean it wasn't that it was
honest and you know she went on she's
married a child and she's good and I
think I'm asking because this is the
first time I'm really seeing the black
women I follow posting about just
because you're dating black men doesn't
mean you're not racist and bringing that
up is so uncomfortable and but because
Muslims people they want you they want
to feel like no she has to be but like
and it's not to discredit my black
sisters or anything like that but what
motherfuckers don't understand is that
you know everybody
a heart you know but a lot of black
women they feel like uh-uh but once
something happens that bitch can be gone
all she just want him for his money
whatever you dealing with a fucking rich
motherfucker you break up it ain't just
like all white chase gonna just get
money everybody's trying to get them
well I think the point is being not
racist isn't enough anymore didn't mean
you now have to be actively anti you
have to fuck a black guy
I mean you I mean I don't know if
there's initiation or whatever like how
many black guys you fuck you're racist
you have to have one black Whitney you
get initiated
yeah but I mean I I just I just might
grab two lovers love very clearly very
explicitly what do you want to see from
me what do you want to see white women
with platforms white men with platforms
non black people with platforms what do
you if you were to give them a homework
assignment for this situation you were
to give them an A+ right now is it
donating is it posting no donated don't
first off you donate to nonprofit half
the times I got so many officers
nonprofit as it takes so long you did
you donate $10,000 mm-hmm whatever the
need is is probably gonna go down to
like $1,000 I just think like I just
what what I want for you is to express
how you feel how you feel that it's
fucked up and the more people that
ignore it and they're silenced by it it
didn't it's not a problem
mm-hmm there has to be a everybody
problem you know I'm saying that doesn't
mean I don't need you to give him the
line you don't saying I don't need you
to donate money but like you wonder feel
that there's some compassion and you
feel like this is fucked up we can move
from that we can grow from that and I
want you to get involved like I said the
civil rights need I said I'm in the 60s
the worst thing they're being called a
nigger
being called a nigger lover that was
worse
nigger lover meant you chose that you
chose that you chose that love but also
said the civil rights movement needed
nigger lovers they needed nigger loves
they needed Freedom Fighters they needed
those Peace Corps bitches and the reason
why I need it I said they need it
because who was gonna get the fucking
marching permits mm-hmm
you know I'm saying a black dude
couldn't go to yo over the DOE nigga who
is it taro what do you want Tyrone who
are those people behind you is that your
posse I need a much permit look at the
ring look at the ring but that said he
said he wants a monster permit ha ha ha
Adam Churchill we need to hear you go
so what I'm saying is that anybody
that's dealing with you talking about
how you feel about this this injustice
is fucked up if you are not ready to get
involved with politics then you're
marching for no fucking reason right
because that's the thing that's gonna
change voting in voting senses signing
up for the census you committed getting
getting involved voting with just in the
census when you focal elections and
federal elections everything you know
I'm sayin motherfuckers you know I'm fun
to just like well I'm just gonna vote in
a general election but you you have to
you have to get involved and we have to
come together we have to make it not
just one race problem but everybody's
problem the unity is what's gonna
motherfucking this wasn't taking Carolla
necessary to Tom Hanks got it New Age
they get whatever it'll bite you right
shit yo what's our heads I should just
get real cast away as the way
Rita hey guess what Rita I got read up
and then you didn't even yeah and you
don't hear anything about it and Tom
Hanks haven't run like certain people
have to be involved before motherfucker
start thinking differently and what is
the role that the pandemic has played in
this moment you II talked a little bit
earlier about it's made it more
stressful mm-hmm because I mean don't
forget I mean there's a large majority
of African Americans are essential
workers yeah I will tell you what one
thing it feels like this fucking shit
that's going on with this killing of
this unarmed black guy it's making us
feel like maybe Corona was a hoax
because it's some no masks weren't no
social distancing practicing
motherfuckers out there like I know this
sounds crazy and that's really the
danger people are so interest they're
not even taking precautions for their
safety and their and their health now
Corona is still out there
mm-hmm and muffins don't give a shit and
what was your reaction I showed you a
video of a couple white girls looting a
Starbucks and writing black lives matter
and a black woman saying please don't do
this they're gonna blame us for this
first of all I commend those black ships
for not beating the shit out of them and
that's another thing they know how to
separate their rage you know I'm saying
like I know you laugh about that but it
could have been like your fuckin white
ass it's i'ma fuck you up they were
smart enough to fall back from me catch
him but that's another thing about this
thing that you know all these people
that start initially they had an example
of a cop in our Minnesota that was it
autozone busting windows open to create
the the the illusion that a riot had
already started and make them all focus
go in there
well that's it's gonna be some people
that they they gonna be smart about this
how do we feel this how do we feel this
there's a lot of people that are right
that are exacerbating this and it you
know so it's really sort of like a very
fine line you know and I'm gonna read
something that someone posted that's
being shared a lot which is before
posting a selfie or a picture of what
you're eating for dinner or your friends
by a pool remember that doing so
actively acknowledges that you have the
free
the time to care about other things
outside the urgent fight for racial
justice so be careful about what you're
choosing to say in this space right now
and ask yourself could this real estate
I'm about to occupy on the Internet be
better suited for something more helpful
dan levy posted that and you know what
that's that's the truth of it when he
like I'm not saying what I'm not saying
we need you I'm not saying that but and
didn't and this was irritating about
some of my friends now like you use your
platform for everything you know you you
know is not just comedy it's certain
issues or the closer you you want to
talk about before this issue it's like I
want to stay away from it analyze my
photos because they're afraid to lose
something they're afraid to lose
something and people don't want to stand
for shit anymore
money is the devil you know I'm saying
Fame as a devil stardom is the devil I
mean this is our life whatever but it
could bring out some fucked up shit in
people too
nobody wants to stand nobody wants to
stand for anything because they're
afraid to lose they're afraid to lose
I'm always but to me at this point if
you're silent you're standing for
something you serve which is the
oppressor you are on set I don't give a
fuck you are speaking really with your
silence and not only yet and expect this
is the you have some people just don't
speak on anything you know I'm saying
but do you got
swift spoke up yeah but the snowball
thing is like this there's a lot of
white people like this who's gonna post
first yes yes yes yes first Natalie yeah
who's post like how much how much like
such a black no it's like penguins when
they push one penguin off the ice here
oh you're all going now it's like who
how much it's okay black lives matter
black lives matter black laws me is it
trending outpost of it's trending yeah
black lives matter my friends got a new
special coming out that last man or new
special what's important me and people
don't want to have you seen anything
with not naming names that's made you
cringe a little or that's been like
that's phony or that's looks
performative that looks like virtue
civilian some post like this have sings
pose was like okay I did it you happy
check the box yeah
it's stand for something mm-hmm I mean
it really at this point is just about
being anti murder which is not that hard
to stand up for me it's ya know well the
hard part we reason wise tough to stand
up for because it's murder of a black
man it's hard to stand up for that it
was a white dude and we all know it'd be
a whole different fucking story
whatever your movie made about it be a
movie made about it Kevin Costner Tom
Hanks to come off a quarantine to shoot
it like you thought some Corona in it
but that's what it is what are some
solutions that you know I think a lot of
people right now are like I don't have
it anybody's why didn't I just why did
you act that funny mom I don't have the
answers I just and me wanting to come up
here today was just like I just wanted
to have a voice just to say like my
frustration with certain things and
doesn't mean it's gonna help anything
it doesn't mean anybody's gonna watch
this and say oh I agree with him
whatever it's just like you know like we
have these platforms you know I'm saying
we have these platforms and it does
sound like like now I think this is the
great time to use our platforms it's
some people backing away from it they
like just I'm just gonna stay and wait
for it to calm down before I speak on it
and I'll commend you for even going it
cuz I know you got a lot of white fans I
got a lot of black fans but it's not
easy to say you know what I want to
listen to what someone has to say I want
to listen to what a black guy well I
also was embarrassed with today
rescheduling and having you come today I
think there's also this this thing of
well now you have to come and teach us
how to think and teach us how you have
now in the in addition to everything
you're going through you now have to
educate us and I think white people have
to but I can't with me I'm not I don't
understand it's your job to educate
yourself it's your job to ask your black
friend to now use their emotional labor
so that you can understand how to be
what I'm talking about today is like how
it like me
a black man how it makes me feel and I'm
looking at your face and you're genuine
I'm saying how it makes me feel to know
that you give a fuck and at the end of
day I don't have to give a fuck that you
give a fuck but it makes me feel that
the message of what's going on is going
further than just angry black people
that are upset that are rightfully upset
it makes me feel better I'm not just oh
shit you know not that we need white
people for to do anything but it makes
me feel good knowing that you give a
fuck it makes me feel good knowing that
you're honest like what do we do
Joe Rogan says okay what do we do what
do we do what'd he do nobody has the
answer but the fact that you give a shit
there's a start people want to criticize
those cops in Miami that kneel down is
bullshit but look okay you think it's
bullshit but for the average person and
that someone is not as critical what did
it symbolize it symbolized that they was
like fuck it they care or at least
understand you know saying and then if
you want our effect if you want to curve
the attitude and you wanted my fuckers
to calm down just a little bit so you
had to move just with rays then you want
to comfort them and you want to make
them feel like listen I don't know your
experience I don't I I don't know about
your spirits I don't know what I could
do but I do think is wrong and help me
mm-hmm
help me understand but I don't have all
the answers right and like I was saying
earlier about my friend that went school
with a Barack Obama you know he was
saying okay most important not the most
important thing but what things need to
do is apprehend these three got didn't
be prosecuted with he said he's like I'm
not against these I'm not gets
protesting he said now if they go to
court and they get acquitted all hell
will break loose I mean it's gonna be if
people think if people think and it's
almost like they are we're we never know
but
if the motherfuckers get acquitted I'll
do some Street shit if they beat these
charges shit is going to fucking burn
it's gonna burn it's going to burn it's
gonna be crazy
it's gonna be it's gonna be the fucking
National Guard it's going to be fucking
war and the fucking thing that I'm
afraid about that okay yeah I want to
stab with his bravery know how that's
gonna end I already know it is gonna end
you're not gonna beat the government
I know husband again it's gonna be
people in a prideful moment like fucking
I did it for that but at the end of day
it's gonna be blood everywhere
it is there's no way around it the
climate of this shit right now
it's like it's a build-up it's a buildup
it's a build-up and it's going to
explode
they're motherfuckers get off you know
I'm saying yo if they get off it's gonna
be Hill there's no way fucking around it
it's gonna be motherfuckers so
interesting to talk about this on this
platform but it's going to be people
dying on both fucking side and awful
shit about it is that I posted something
other day and it was my body split black
and blue you know I'm saying and I
wasn't trying to close that's how I feel
you know saying I'm black I have the
mindset of slightly blue because when I
was in the military I was a police
officer all my closest friends my life
long friends I've known for years and
years they retired from him my PD some
of my friends were Capitol Police so I
know it's easy sided fuck the police
but I can't say fuck the police I'm
saying fuck my friends and that's not
fucking fair and I know what's so fucked
up about it was fucking about because
it's gonna cause so much shit with me
with families
i watch the video the other day and i
don't know what instigated wet but what
I saw it was a cop trying to detain
somebody or something I don't know the
circumstances that some of a cop was by
herself or not well it wasn't on people
room right he was trying to kick each
other's guy and then I saw like till my
phone's just jump on a cop some people
might say dismantle I trying to say down
here I felt sorry for both I felt sad
for both I was upset
I don't know that cop story hmm I don't
know if that cop was there he didn't
feel good about it but his captain said
you got to go out there I don't know I
don't know what the end of that was I
don't know if there was a the people
that he was coming in contact with if
they ever see I don't know what happened
to him but I was sad for both sides of
it and that's the fucked up shit I can't
just I can't just say fuck all police
and I know black people now community is
so easy not to like the police officers
isn't that how do you feel about have
you seen the defund police initiative
what is it - basically divert funds I
mean because our military's basically
our police our militarized in a lot of
ways like how do you feel about
eventually at some point moving away
from the amount of force police are
allowed to use I do well thing is what's
going to happen we can't just handicap
cops because we also got to understand
there's gonna be a continued criminal
element out there and and I guarantee
you the police department can't wait for
one of them to die is they will I see
what happens
mhm you don't saying but we need it we
need more rules you need outside agency
that's gonna please police because you
got internal affairs they internal
affairs they in they in with each other
you know I'm saying but a personal I
just this is we need to consider to a
person like that guy is like you gotta
motherfucker with a resume yeah a resume
you gotta have you gotta take a
psychological exam when you first become
a police officer when I was trying to be
a police officer in DC I had to take a
psychological exam Connie came and I
just said fuck that shit cuz to be quite
honest most remote the average police is
not a police because they want to be a
cop
the average cop is a cop because they
looked at it as a secure job when when
when they have a hiring freeze then when
they start hiring cops again the way
they promote it in the newspapers
everything's like they don't never talk
about risk your life you don't talk
about protecting it first thing he says
the first thing I mentioned is a salary
first thing I miss is the salary what do
I get paid in DC at that time it was
probably like 40 $45,000 if I'm correct
but what I'm saying is it was enough for
somebody that was stuck with you what
they gonna do you don't even you know
you needs a high school diploma pass a
psychological exam is some bullshit test
almost anybody can be a cop so those
people you got this a profession that
people don't love to do
same way with black people most black
people in military most black people
military in that patriotic it's like yo
I was gonna go to college I wasn't gonna
do this this is a good option for me
even when they recruit for police that's
what they tell you they don't say you
know what in four years you could kill a
bigot
they say hey you wanna make fifty
thousand our Nets without overtime
benefits perfect that's what they sell
you on don't you get in they they they
they flip the script on you so you
already dealing with somebody that don't
fucking wannabe do why not have some
shit you have to take a psychological
exam when you first become a cop to
become a cop why not every two or three
years you have another psychological
exam if you got a motherfucker
they're shooting niggas every shooting
at motherfuckers every three to four
weeks you need to talk to that
motherfucker
and if you don't want to talk to him and
you want to prove
or you want to still stay with the old
boys ship then get this nigga off the
street regroup and if you are get him on
the force and see his behavior you
report him I mean you know like there is
no consequences
the cops are no consequences so they
could be fucking they could do whatever
the fuck they want but the more
motherfucker start going to jail the
morning start getting arrested the more
you start saying god damn that was my
friend he's doing 25 years he's doing 30
years he's not going out then you want
to think different and you would think
that the police cameras would have some
kind of impact I mean the first thing I
thought when I was watching that video
was this guy knew he was being filmed
imagine what hasn't been caught on film
exactly imagine what hasn't years in
caught on film 100% correct but thank
god that's a situation like whether we
know it or not things are changing that
whether we know it or not things are
changing because the idea of a cop just
even being arrested like 20 years ago
Dettol doesn't make sense so we are
moving in the right direction it's just
not happening fast enough I saw Andrew
Cuomo man I love this dude so much just
by his honesty and he doesn't try to
fucking lie to you just plain and simple
when he when he did that brief another
day he spoke about that how things have
been changed from 30 years ago and then
when he said see this was
misunderstanding he said I'm with the
protesters but then people would take
that as do you you mean the ones that
are fucking vandalized shit
no I said I'm with the protesters not to
write how can you not be mm-hmm and if
you're not it's fucked up no white woman
did even crack a smile didn't even
change her face didn't even look me
right in my face but these goddamn
unsalted nuts
you were just lady was like was it a
moment
blacklivesmatter blasio amber blobs man
I'm totally just numb with guilt I've
been having like an out-of-body
experience you know it's funny and I
keep on saying is like wondering one of
my friends we were talking about it like
toughest thing for us to do is like like
through all this how do we cuz we got to
keep our funny right yeah and I said I
feel like I've been hilarious this
podcast
yeah we've it's but it's also I think
this fine line of like also stop playing
for a second and like you know and I
think comedians what we do is we say
what no one else will say we'll make
jokes but but then also we need to know
when to say things no one else will say
even if it's serious shit your heart
your heart speaks volumes I mean I'm
saying we always gonna even I told you
those times my like when I didn't feel
funny I knew was gonna come back but
right now you got shit and there is a um
I was like yo you gonna post some shit
whatever tells like this do you have a
brand economy with this we'll call me
does comedy makes people laugh then they
could think later you know say I was
like you know what I'm like this you
know what I know you important for your
brand to be funny and honest shit yeah
but I was like this you know be some
kind of funny we did we wrote a letter
to each other
I'm do I just play dear white person you
know indeed you saw I would dear black
guy and ask an ex honest questions and
then not that you looking for comedy but
there will be something funny in a
response each other get and did you
learn something and also just in the
tension release you know I mean that's
having uncomfortable conversations
there's been time during this or I'm
sure I've laughed it weird moments it's
like you know it's like laughter just
sometimes comes there's no such thing
yeah we there's no such thing as a weird
moment in comedy yeah it's the moment
when it happens there's no such thing
but people like sometimes people confuse
being a comedian with being a clown
that's right
you don't say you're a philosopher
really exactly they think like oh yeah
oh my be funny like a mop
I've been called sensitive really I
don't know what comedian is not sense
I think highly intelligent highly
sensitive but I also think an obsession
with justice is sort of what your common
denominator with all of us anonymous and
yeah that's what keeps us going I got a
fucking comb complain about this thing
because I think it's unjust yes that's
out then like I can't tell people how to
use their platform but I just especially
people that are close to me
I wish there used their platform for
that you can always go back to the jokes
mm-hmm but this is a very very critical
time in the world for some reason like
we're doing this shit like doing a
pandemic motherfuckers don't know when
you can go back to work people don't
know when you're gonna feel comfortable
people are dying
you're not being at you can't say
goodbye to your loved ones you don't say
my mom is older you know I'm saying I
was just thing about it was a weird
thought I was like oh my god I can't
even imagine because something happened
to her and you can't have a period yeah
period my mom's a nursing home like we
can't have a funeral you know yep
I'm like white people go to nursing home
you just go to your cousins are you like
unsalted nuts just like those black
people that's so funny and you said how
was I nurse and I was like nursing all
but it would be devastating something
have you spoken to her my mom in last
week you always be my mother say she's
been my mother hates Trump it does
however since the start uh we need to
get him out of here but my mother think
that anything that happened in the world
she think I was close to it yo we okay
no he rubs in Hawaii she was like you
was just saying why three years ago you
okay baby like I am NOT everything like
last night these moms are like in
Minneapolis yeah
but last night they were looting in or
melrose my mother caught me today you
could I would have felt you cared really
mom you caught last night
you know like you slip on it you step on
it as soon as I baby you not down in
that stuff are you I'm like ma I'm not
looting at Target if that's what you
asked me but that just said mom just
came by but my mom has it my mom is um
she's older woman so she just like she
just thinks different like everything is
trumps what did you what was your
reaction to Trump writing thugs in a
tweet he could the reason why he wrote
thoughts because he know that if he
woulda said nigger tweeted Twitter would
have they wouldn't post that's his code
word sandwich he probably really want to
say and thug like you
you trying to shift it what makes them
thugs and okay talk about the people
that are criminal minded to use an
opportunity to commit a crime
don't try to you tryna say thug the each
other you try to say thug as protesters
it's not the same thing but you can't
you every time so many times the last
seven years that there was times where
because like when David he said I'm
gonna give him a shot right cuz you
think like okay these are the tactics he
used to get in office you might not
necessarily feel that way I believed it
but it was so many times I was like you
know what this is a time when he could
make everybody feel like he's for
everybody and every time that happens he
has our returning feel like he's for the
people it doesn't make he doesn't make
you feel like that he makes me feel like
I'm for the people that voted for me I'm
for those people and I'm so burnt with
it like I really don't care who you
voted for
I think
I hear so many people like well you know
if you voted for Trump you just can't be
my friend I can't say that because the
amount of money he's saving my taxes
last year I will not we're making money
your hat but if you got a do-rag and
this is the this is the and I'm not a
supporter but I'm like my mother was
like a Geico commercial use unsalted
nuts right everybody put your mother
nursing with you man but I was like and
I said this on different platforms like
if I didn't care about you man if I
didn't care about like health care and
some of the things that he's trying to
take away like me being of a small
business yeah that's what we are
yeah that's me being a small business
and me being a veteran those are two
things that a person like me could say
I'm not voting for a person I'm voting
for policies you know I'm saying like
I'm like yo shit you know but my heart
just won't let me be supportive of his
actions in a person he is and I know
people you get a Sibley's business but
this would have to say this boy
he doesn't think would like emotion he
thinks like a shrewd businessperson and
a true business person don't give a fuck
about this hundred people that work for
this company we're losing money you
gotta get fire you gotta fire you know
that's it and that's what people can't
understand but the only way that you can
like you can bitch and you can say all
you want the only way you get rid of
this situation is to vote him out I
think that Joe Biden and I said this
before it's like he reminds me of why I
got it slept with a couple of black
chicks in high school is shit they just
think he got a pass he be like oh yeah
I think that what he said I think that
it was um I think it was a political
locker room
talk you don't say I think he was trying
to be funny
Oh 100% why he delivered it it's like
you ever delivered joking you like so
yes they go out here all week yo roll
don't make jokes unzoom they're all go
get him Bob if you can see how he leaned
into it right it's like it's it's like
he leaned into a light didn't he said he
tried to land it yeah you ain't but like
it was gonna be like good night
everybody def Comedy Jam you know it was
easy then you ain't black okay you feel
free to pass how do you feel about black
leadership and police forces is it
imperative that we have black leadership
in order to go in the right direction I
don't know if isn't but I think it's we
gotta have the most honest people
because when it comes to police
department you know a lot of times you
know it's black and blue but a lot of
time the black police are because
they're a unit they got a heavy each
other's back every day so nine times out
of ten even if you're black you're gonna
side with what that police department
goes with more than anything yeah you
don't want to lose your job and you
don't want have son you don't want
someone not to have your back and it's
it's it's it's a it's a it's a
brotherhood it's a problem
Wow it's a brotherhood that's it wow you
want to make sure you're protected
that's what I thought the first thing I
thought was like you know what we need
more black chief yeah but goddamn I
didn't see some black Kassadin beat
motherfuckers up our than any white
person do part of is because I want to
show you that I'm down with the force
more than anything and some have grudges
and resentment about about black people
anyway it's a tough job for a black
person become a cop that's a tough job
my father was a life he's passed away
r.i.p my dad
Charles box love you um my father was a
heroin dealer almost all of his fucking
life um when I told him I was running
military and I was gonna be a cop he
looked like I let him down he was like
you know what this is so crazy you know
was a proud moment my father's life
would
when I got arrested was locked up for 48
hours it was so funny he was like yes I
I knew out of all my kids he was gonna
be the one and I was like thanks dad
you really see me yeah he was like and
um I don't think that he wanted me to go
to jail but I think he wanted me to see
how I feel to get your freedom taken
away from you see how it feels for
somebody to treat you less than what you
thought you this is a weird this is a
weird thing for me to say that's such a
weird thing for some reason in a black
community if a motherfucker went to jail
no this sounds crazy but some place it
feels like a proud moment I heard him
off I ain't never been locked up maybe
you don't know about the street crowd
your honor
yeah almost almost like you don't you
don't know what it is to go through the
system and you got some people that are
locked up for committing crimes you got
some innocent people locked up too but
for some reason we got to get away from
that - it's like something about
glorifying it you did was there part of
your dad that was relieved just so you
saw the reality of how things were just
gonna be different yeah but he was kind
of like oh shit he never talked about
that I know he was kind of like so tough
he says but it was like kind of like
cool pops oh yeah and then he was like
but then bits motherfucker you only did
two days that ain't shit
this is original huh you know wooden or
sink um I'll take them out of take this
is obviously a very very young person
asked to this question why does this
only happen in the United States so
someone who hasn't read their history
book and we're going to switch it
Whitney gets the answer black questions
yo its Donnelly your word to everything
I love doing say Google slavery yeah
that's a quick google maybe just Google
slavery it might make your algorithm a
little while they figure out that the
but think about that this maybe that's
not being taught black everyone is dead
where they were where are they getting
this from right as 2021 and like that's
not even a issue with them yeah you've
seen Beyonce you've seen Liz oh you've
seen success like our people really
learning like you almost in a song it's
unfortunate but the engine once you
think you forget about the history of
American black history incidents like
this happen is like ah that's it that's
Europe feel free to pass on this someone
want to say did Jimmy Fallon do the
right thing and apologizing for the
blackface sketch of Chris Rock yes he
did right someone wrote but when I leave
but yeah he did the right thing someone
said sometimes I think don't be racist
when I interact with black people am i
racist um if you have to ask that
question you probably are but there's
different levels of it you know I'm
saying you got stuff that I think
culturally like motherfuckers doing
jokes about Italians Asians in Indians
and stuff like that but I don't think
did you it like um I don't think you're
the type of races that could fuck
anybody up that could call somebody a
job or anything like that and for me
that's kind of a difference you know and
for some people that are completely
racist Joe we say racist joke but just
it
does it hurt you you know
my wit comedians means we push
boundaries on everything I know it was
like old shit but you really find out
what am I fucking don't laugh okay
what's your reaction to people who want
to respond to black lives matter posts
with but shouldn't all lives matter
yeah they should but all lives didn't
have an e on their neck you know I'm
saying this is it this is a different
circumstance I believe I do believe that
all lies man but me as a black person my
life to my blackness man is first but
also I think for the people that are
confused white lives already matter yeah
that they don't need a movement to tell
people not to murder them yeah and
what's your situation to say that and
why do all lives matter now you say the
black lives matter blue lives matter we
do understand that but blue lives aren't
getting murdered because of their skin
colour and also when people say will
shun all lives matter well that should
include black lives and right now they
don't matter as much so all lives matter
can we just get a goddamn week what it's
all about
nobody celebrate Black History Month we
just got damn yeah
like did you know that the Church of
Satan came out and protested I don't
know the Church of Satan is is speaking
up for black lives matter if the Church
of Satan believes this is yeah would you
ever do hot wax foreplay that's what is
it that's a baby what is it it's where
you take the wax of a candle and pour it
on the other person oh yeah I've done
that before
oh really just give the pouring or the
receiving of the pouring no I pour I was
a pro I'm not gonna do this no idea but
I've had poured two waxes but I got
crazy I just started all over the place
man you got to like you got to really
respect somebody that respects oh can I
get your opinion on one more thing I was
reading Rachel cargo scooter and she
said stop saying racially motivated say
racist what happens when you see someone
say this was rated racially motivated it
was motivated because they're racist so
just
I think there's a lot of words that that
dilute what's happening my fucked up
fillings are by fucked up feelings
toward a black person is the reason why
I need and show just mother fuck out to
death
what do you need what will deter no
matter what the turn don't matter what
are the actions sometimes when people
are speaking out they tend to sanitize
something because they don't want to use
a you know this was racially motivated
it's racist
it's racist like yeah you gotta edit
yourself just like even with stand-up
man if you editing yourself inside your
brain before you say it too much yeah
it's not your real truth that's right
you know let it ride you're gonna learn
you want to learn if you're a racist say
some fucked up shit you'll find out real
quick that was racist and if you're
white and uncomfortable that's fine
you're gonna have to be uncomfortable
there is nothing wrong with being white
and uncountable but it's also good to
know what you're uncomfortable about and
you can learn about that you can learn
from that yeah this is very tough time
with me you know some people don't want
to hear anything I see it some people
don't to hit anything you say but the
more important the more important thing
about this conversation and you have me
up here today's such short notice that
we got to create some type of dialogue
and we got to make this an issue that
disturbs everybody and not just the
people that are victims of it and you
have a responsibility with your platform
and even if you don't know what the fuck
you're talking about ask someone who
does too if you yes the thing that
they're going back to that the thing is
so troubling about it if you're a
motherfucker is just on post and posted
post and post it and you just choose to
ignore what's going on the real world
that's the fucking delusion that people
don't want to deal with and that's when
it comes to your character you know
you're not that real person that you
portray your social media is just
bullshit you could be anybody and also
if you don't know what to say
retweet someone who does know what to
say read your hosts repost Darnell type
of thing we can do right now is to be
funny hmm
but this is a quote from a good friend
of mine it's like now is the time for
men to grab their balls women gravity
always because it's our job to make fun
of the things that's troubling the world
and that's what separates the good ones
from
I love you I love you too thank you for
thank you for doing this thank you for
these nuts no I'm just saying thank you
you know ah yeah yeah which by the way I
feel a little less guilty because you
were supposed to do the pot a couple of
months ago and you thought that I was
just a reckless
Rhona bitch no I didn't say that oh you
was like yeah no that's not what it was
no go to Whole Foods to get nuts no you
was like just use like this you good on
the Rona I was like bitch you good owner
owner like two weeks into the quarantine
I was like let's just do it in person
well you're the first one but you know
that was like that was right off the top
that was when everybody was I was like
does she know what's going on right now
hey Daniel come to the block is out like
motherfucker Rona I'm like no comedy
wins Kylie laughter is the best medicine
wonder it but we had a good place with
the person I came yeah I'm almost happy
because we talked about this I was so
happy when you first came into the
podcast world and inspired me I was like
god damn it could be done by somebody
that not necessarily some people just
like this all I had but you got a lot of
options and shit and then like I've been
listening to it like your voice gets
strong and it's like certain people
Rogan says certain people are born to do
this you're born to do it so I
appreciate your voice and I appreciate
you being able to talk to me about this
I don't know if you learned anything I
don't have the answer to everything but
the fact that again creating dialogue
and and understanding what's on people's
minds it means a lot lot of things will
be questioned to Ana's period
friendships and everything hmm I got
about three or four right now I'm like
do I really want to fuck me I know
people didn't why because I just I just
feel like oh oh sorry they don't say
that about you you say that about that
yeah I really like it's showing people's
character like you said I think for me I
don't pretend to be a pundit I don't
pretend to be an expert I know my place
but it's also become very clear that
silence is
lining with the opposition and your
oppressor and our The Voice and we have
a voice so as much as we want to
continue to make people laugh and
everything like that you know at certain
times like where where the laughter
stops and we pick it back up yeah and if
you don't know what to say amplify
someone who does know what to say
retweet someone else
the donnell rawlings podcast is
available everywhere yes the down air on
a podcast 25 episodes in I having a good
time
uncensored unedited and it's just me
take it or leave I love it you have so
much fun of the show in your opening
song is unn dallisa dude it makes you
want to like yo I had is why do sit man
my neighbors get upset cuz I just start
banging the fucking walls when it come
on it's just
RZA gaming that beat and when I asked
him I said could you give me a beat he
said yeah I'm not gonna give me any
hip-hop I said my musical shit goes
further than just hip-hop and he came to
classical beat him somebody said that's
not a rap beat he didn't give me to beat
the rap off of he gave me to be to
create off love that's a movie score and
I fucking love it it's like it's like
makes you feel strong like you're
invincible yeah yeah I'm gonna like
fight like a superhero yeah makes you
want to pour wax on a white bitch back
I've just said that would be so funny
I'm getting ideas now like why did you
let a poor wax all of you did you hear
that RZA beep can you blame me that's
that's how we're gonna figure this shit
out man
the next I go to a protest we gonna play
that recipe muffled it's gonna go ahead
and don't don't throw them just throw
instead of mace and everything just
black ash candlelit everyone Superman
thank you so much thank you I always had
these very awkwardly in my bio and in my
stories I'm linking to how to donate
bail money to protesters just go to my
stories and I'm putting a bunch of
places that you guys can donate and then
posting everything I'm donating to
because it really bothers me when
Hollywood people tell everyone else to
donate and
they don't do themselves it's fucking
annoying so that's all on my story so
you guys know that I'm not completely
full of shit love you guys thank you so
much
Donnell Rawlings
[Music]
you
[Applause]